et voilà c'était sommet dans le secret
des négociations européennes un film
réalisé par Yann Anthony Noguès bonjour
vous êtes le réalisateur de ce film et
vous nous faites l'honneur de participer
à Z la Zone d'Éducation documentaire
merci beaucoup à vos côtés Antoine
Chabal bonjour vous êtes le président
des Jeunes Européens France c'est une
association qui défend mais surtout qui
promeut l'idée d'une Europe fédérale si
je me trompe pas alors pour nous
expliquerait tout ça plus en détail
enfin surtout vous l'expliquerez aux
élèves du lycée Val-de-Seine bonjour les
élèves
alors parmi vous on trouve des secondes
des premières déterminales et vous
participez tous à un atelier Sciences Po
c'est ça alors je sais que vous avez
étudié décortique et regardez ce film
vous avez plein de questions à poser à
nos deux invités mais juste avant
j'aimerais connaître votre ressenti
votre sentiment sur ce film ce qui est
intéressant dans ce reportage c'est
qu'on peut voir les chefs d'État sans
filtre on peut voir leurs apartés
pendant les interviews justement et
c'est ça qui est intéressant pour pour
nous la jeunesse de pouvoir voir les
chefs d'État dans un autre cadre de voir
que en fait ce sont des personnes tout à
l'heure c'est normal et du coup c'est ça
vraiment qui est intéressant aussi dans
ce reportage et comment il est tourné en
fait quand j'ai regardé le documentaire
c'est vraiment ce que j'ai ressenti je
vais l’impression de regarder une série
un petit peu comme House of Cards c'est
ce que j'ai aimé c'était que jusqu'au
bout j'avais envie de savoir ce qui se
passait et du coup j'ai vraiment compris
en fait les enjeux surtout que à la base
l'Union européenne pour moi c'est
quelque chose d'austère enfin alors que
là jusqu'à la fin j'ai envie de
découvrir en fait qu'est-ce qui allait
se passer quelle décision et aller à
l'être prise quoi c'est un bon
compliment
si vous deviez me décrire me définir
l'Europe en un mot je dirais l'Union
l'Union rédoine collaboration un autre
mot suric solidarité
Erasmus Lucas ok est-ce que vous pouvez
me citer trois députés européens
non c'est difficile attends excuse-moi
Tom c'est ça je pense à Jordan Bardella
pour le rassemblement national par
exemple d'autres
Lucas bien
ça vous parle aussi peut-être ok
Nathalie Loiseau enfin voilà comme ça on
fait un peu tous les parties politiques
Nathalie Loiseau pour donc la majorité
la République en marche Manon Brie pour
la France insoumise allez je vais
arrêter là l'interro surprise
et on va passer à vos questions et on
commence par Clélia combien de temps
vous avez mis pour tourner et créer le
reportage alors on a mis un mois à faire
le documentaire celui là c'est
particulier parce qu'on sait on s'est
concentré sur un sommet et on a suivi
Charles Michel à partir du moment où il
est entré en fonction jusqu'à ce sommet
qui a eu lieu donc 15 jours 15 jours
plus tard on a voulu se mettre dans la
tête d'un président d'institutions
européennes qui lui-même découvre sa
fonction
et vous avez remarqué que dans ce
documentaire il n'y a pas de voix il y a
pas de voix journalistique ce sont les
chefs d'État du gouvernement eux-mêmes
et leurs équipes qui racontent
l'histoire et ça c'est pour donner ce
sentiment d'immersion et vraiment d'être
avec eux les 27
des journalistes vous avez des collègues
de voilà de tous les pays européens lors
des sommets européens il y a plus de
1000 journalistes à crudités donc ce
soit télévision radio très sécrétes web
maintenant oui oui c'est très suivi on
parle de 27 États membres plus le reste
du monde et les décisions qui sont
prises là
ils ont une portée très importante
c'est pour savoir dans quels étaient les
conditions de tournage si vous avez du
renoncé à certaines prises
c'est une bonne question parce que c'est
difficile en fait d'une on doit faire
des choix mais ensuite j'ai une sorte de
deal avec Charles Michel qui m'accueille
dans ses bureaux c'est à dire que je lui
dis voilà on va se faire confiance je
sais qu'il y a des choses qui sont top
secrètes confidentielles très sensible
et je sais que ça vous voulez pas que ça
apparaisse dans le documentaire
mais s'il vous plaît laissez-moi filmer
et ensuite c'est moi qui ferai le choix
de ce que je garde et ce que je garde
pas sachant que je veux pas vous mettre
en difficulté mais ne nous bridez pas et
ne choisissez pas vous ce qu'on peut
filmer ce qu'on peut pas filmer parce
que sinon les hommes politiques ils ont
tendance à juste nous laisser filmer le
moment où ils sont victorieux le moment
où il y a une belle décision et le
moment où ça marche pour eux mais quand
ils sont un peu dans le creux de la
vague ça ils ont pas envie qu'on filme
et c'est ça que nous on voulait filmer
on voulait montrer ces moments de doute
les moments où ça marche pas les moments
où il se dit bon sang le deal va capoter
alors que c'est mon premier deal et je
vais passer pour un naze auprès de
auprès des 450 millions d'Européens et
c'est ce qui fait la force le sel d'une
histoire voilà bref encore plus précis
et pour poursuivre ta question jamais on
vous a dit stop là vous sortez ah oui si
bien sûr
pour vous est-ce que vous étiez le seul
réalisateur à pouvoir filmer cette
partie du documentaire ou est-ce que il
pouvait aussi y avoir des des autres
réalisateurs étrangers comme des
Allemands ou bien des Anglais la
question est très bonne et je vais vous
dire quelque chose qui va m'enlever
beaucoup de mérite je crois que j'étais
à peu près le seul que ça intéressait
parce que a priori se dire waouh je peux
filmer en exclusivité au sein du Conseil
européen c'est excite pas grand monde
mais en fait quand on connaît les
affaires européennes quand on sait ce
qui s'y passe quand on devine où on veut
savoir ce qui s'y passe c'est excitant
vous avez 27 chefs d'État et de
gouvernement en gros 27 Macron qui ils
sont tous numéro 1 dans leur pays c'est
des égaux surdimensionnés sont des
enjeux colossaux on parle de dizaines de
centaines de
milliers de milliards d'euros on parle
de notre avenir on parle de la guerre de
la défense on parle de tout et donc ce
qui se passe là c'est très fort ils ont
tous des convictions très fortes ils ont
tous des opinions publiques qui les
attendent à la maison quand ils vont
revenir de ce sommet là et si jamais ils
ont pris une décision où ils ont accepté
ils ont laissé faire quelque chose qui
n'allait pas dans leur sens
ça peut être très dommageable pour eux
donc c'est vraiment 27 fauves dans une
arène et on se retrouve avec Charles
Michel et lui il a pas de fouet il a
juste sa petite clochette et c'est ça
qui nous amusait mais si tu avais une
question
nous on se demandait comment vous avez
pu avoir accès à la salle des conseils
alors qu'on demandait à tout le monde de
sortir pour une raison confidentialité
ça se joue à plein de choses
c'est-à-dire que par exemple notre
caméraman
son brief je devrais pas donner tous ces
trucs là on avait dit on avait dit au
cameraman déjà toi s'il te plaît
mets-toi en costume cravate d'accord et
mets-toi un pin's européen ou je sais
pas quoi déjà et ça lui permettait
d'être dans les délégations des chefs
d'État et au moment vous savez quand un
chef d'État passe dans un couloir et que
il y a des accès ou autre il a toujours
des gens avec avec des dossiers des
femmes en tailleur des amants costumes
qui suivent et là les agents de sécurité
ils doivent vite prendre la décision qui
peut passer qui peut pas passer etc et
s'il voit quelqu'un en basket qui est
petite caméra ou un truc ou quoi il se
dit oui bon ça c'est un journaliste
celui-là il peut pas passer alors que
s'il voit un caméraman avec un costume
cravate là il dit oui il fait partie de
la délégation celui-là il va pouvoir
passer c'est bête mais c'est des petits
trucs comme ça la fameuse scène en avait
pas vraiment le droit d'être là dans la
salle du conseil à ce moment là
et en fait on avait demandé à notre
caméraman de se mettre le plus loin
possible dans la salle pour être le
dernier à être appelé
parmi les journalistes qui devaient
sortir et quitter la salle et il s'est
même mis derrière un extincteur
et c'est ce qui lui a permis de rester
plus longtemps que les autres et d'avoir
ces fameuses 5 minutes qui avait jamais
été vu à la télévision alors Manon tu as
une question pour Antoine Chavanne
pouvez-vous nous expliquer ce qu'est le
Conseil européen et comment il
fonctionne
c'est une des institutions de l'Union
européenne et le Conseil européen
rassemble les 27 chefs d'État de tous
les États membres de l'Union européenne
c'est un petit peu voilà l'institution
qui les regroupe tous ou ils prennent
des décisions ensemble et ils décident
des grandes orientations pour l'Union
des grands objectifs que qu'il va
falloir attendre c'est exactement ce qui
se passe dans le reportage j'ai fixe les
grands objectifs ils doivent trouver un
accord pour pour voilà les grandes
orientations de l'Union pour les
prochaines années alors Léonor on
t'écoute tu as une question aussi pour
Antoine Chabat donc comment s'articulent
les différentes entités donc le Conseil
européen le la Commission européenne et
le Parlement européen quels sont leurs
différences et comment cela fonctionne
alors je vous l'ai dit le Conseil
européen fixe les grandes orientations
et avec ça on a deux autres institutions
principales vous l'avez dit la
Commission européenne elle Parlement
européen ce qu'on appelle le triangle
institutionnel pour schématiser un petit
peu et
la Commission européenne c'est un petit
peu l'exécutif c'est la Commission qui a
aussi l'initiative des lois qui propose
on le voit dans le documentaire qui
propose un document sur lequel les chefs
d'état d'un côté mais aussi les
parlementaires européens vont discuter
ensuite et la troisième institution qui
complète ce triangle c'est le Parlement
européen c'est la seule institution avec
des représentants directement élus par
les citoyens européens et des élections
européennes tous les 5 ans et eux aussi
travaillent sur les textes les amendes
et complète un petit peu ce trio Antoine
vous vraiment des interventions auprès
des jeunes c'est même un peu le bah
voilà l'objectif de votre de votre
association
comment vous expliquer aujourd'hui qu'on
est tant de mal et d'ailleurs vous le
disiez aussi il y a Anthony Noguès qu'on
ne comprennent pas cette institution que
ce soit éloigné que ce soit compliqué
pourquoi mine de rien on en parle assez
peu dans les médias ou parfois un peu
trop mal aussi et on se rend compte que
on en parlant dans toutes les
interventions qu'on peut faire auprès de
jeunes dans les écoles ou ailleurs c'est
pas si compliqué ça nous paraît loin
parce que on entend peu parler mais
c'est pas si compliqué en tout cas
peut-être pas plus que notre système
institutionnel français avec le Sénat
l'Assemblée nationale soit tout ça en
fait il suffit que voilà on est quelques
infos on creuse un tout petit peu et on
se rend compte que finalement on peut on
peut mettre du sens sur le
fonctionnement toutes ces institutions
et surtout réaliser à quel point c'est
important c'est intéressé parce que ça a
vraiment un impact sur notre quotidien
au plus près de nous finalement on
continue avec toi
entre les dirigeants et elle s'en sert
ou surjouée les deux
parfois elle est sincère et ils veulent
pas le montrer
et parfois elle est inexistante mais il
la surjoue donc
c'est comme je sais pas combien vous
êtes dans cet atelier là vous êtes une
trentaine
c'est la même chose vous connaissez à
peu près tous mais après il y a des
questions d'affinité si jamais vous
devez travailler en groupe vous allez
voir avec qui vous avez envie d'être
soit parce que c'est quelqu'un que vous
aimez bien soit parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est doué ou ça c'est
quelqu'un qui va faire le boulot et en
fait au sein même du Conseil européen
c'est la même chose il s’est une classe
ils sont 27 et il y a des clivages entre
eux
d'ordre différents c'est-à-dire que il y
a ceux qui sont de gauche et droite très
important ça on se rend pas compte mais
les clivages politiques sont vraiment
essentielles avant chaque sommet et on
le voit d'ailleurs dans le documentaire
il se retrouve au sein de leur propre
famille politique et ensuite il y a
aussi les clivages Nord-Sud très
important les clivages est-ouest et ça
va dépendre des dossiers c'est à dire
que
voilà c'est la géométrie variable et en
fonction du dossier qui est sur la table
il y a différents groupes différentes
différents mouvements qui qui sont à
l'oeuvre ça c'est ça c'est intéressant à
suivre Redouane
c'est selon vous pourquoi l'image de
l'Europe est-elle toujours si éloignée
alors que comme on a pu le voir dans le
documentaire elle est à l'initiative de
plusieurs mesures qui sont très
importantes pour nous tous ici et pour
l'avenir et selon vous
faudrait-il alors mieux expliquer son
rôle
alors je pense qu'il y a plusieurs
choses qui expliquent ce sentiment
d'éloignement on parlait du fait que on
en parle suffisamment pas suffisamment
parfois un peu trop mal aussi peut-être
un autre élément dont on peut parler
c'est justement on évoquait tout à
l'heure le jeu que peuvent jouer aussi
les chefs d'État c'est le fameux bouc
émissaire qui est l'Europe c'est si tout
va bien c'est grâce à nous si tout va
mal c'est la faute à l'Europe et ça ça
revient souvent et je pense que ça
dessert un petit peu forcément l'image
de l'Union européenne et du rôle qu'elle
a très concret dont on parlait et c'est
aussi en étant nous chacun d'entre nous
plus éclairé sur ce que ça apporte très
concrètement encore une fois dans nos
vies quotidiennes à quel point c'est pas
si éloigné que que voilà on comprendra
mieux on sera aussi plus critique sur
sur ce qu'on entend et sur ce qu'on nous
dit à propos de l'Union européenne
comment vous analysez le le rôle le rôle
de l'Europe à travers ce cette crise
cette guerre en Ukraine
comment vous regardez l'Europe et
comment vous l'analysez oui Camille
joue un rôle de médiateur faut qu'on
soit plus ferme avec Vladimir Poutine et
pas qu'on suive simplement et décision
des États-Unis et par honte tu entends
l'Europe par an j'entends l'Europe
Poutine jusqu'ici
pour lui Bruxelles pour lui l'Europe ça
n'existait pas et il avait pas intérêt à
ce que ça existe il a pas intérêt à
avoir parce que innovant du gaz
aujourd'hui et il est ravi de dire aux
roumain de dire au hongrois de dire au
Polonais aller toi je te fais tel prix
tu as été gentil allez toi je te fais un
bon prix aussi tu as été gentil dans toi
toi tu vas prendre cher et en fait c'est
comme ça qu'il nous divise s'il se
retrouve avec une centrale d'achat
groupé s'il se retrouve avec 27 pays qui
sont tous ensemble face à lui il a
beaucoup moins de marge de manoeuvre
c'est vraiment divisé pour mieux régner
en tout cas sur les questions des de
l'énergie
Poutine ce qui est assez intéressant
c'est que honnêtement il prend l'Europe
pour un nain politique l'Europe c'est un
géant économique mais c'est un humain
politique et il avait raison jusqu'ici
Vladimir Poutine on l'a entendu
d'ailleurs dans une de ses allocutions
télévisées il a il a dit à quoi ça sert
d'être bon
sous-entendu les occidentaux ou les
Européens si on est là chez faible moi
je veux être courageux et je vais être
fort et c'est là où c'est en train de
changer parce que l'Union européenne
maintenant et non seulement dans des
bons enfin en tout cas
notre façon d'appréhender le monde mais
en plus ça fait preuve de fermeté et de
courage Zurich tu as une question
question pour vous deux pensez-vous que
l'Union européenne est trop dépendante
des États-Unis et qu'elle n'arrive pas à
s'imposer réellement sur la scène
internationale
question pour vous deux
je pense que c'est une question qu'il
faut prendre plus globalement est-ce que
l'Union européenne est pas trop
dépendante de manière générale de
d'autres puissances étrangères et là on
le voit avec l'actualité géopolitique ça
pose de vraies questions sur l'état de
la défense européenne sur l'état de la
puissance économique de l'Union
européenne qui est indéniable c'est l'un
des plus grosses et le plus gros marché
mondial est-ce que il serait pas de
temps et je pense que le temps il était
déjà il y a un moment de véritablement
se donner les moyens aussi de cette
puissance on l'entend de plus en plus
dans la bouche de certains de certaines
femmes et de certains hommes politiques
mais ça c'est voilà c'est une chose à
laquelle on croit vraiment aux jeunes
européens c'est l'Europe est une
puissance il faut qu'elle se donne les
moyens de sa puissance
face
aux influences étrangères ça peut être
celle des États-Unis mais celle d'autres
puissances étrangères qui mais qui sont
pas il faut pas voir non plus ces
influences tu parlais de des États-Unis
comme une influence forcément négative
je pense que dans le contexte
géopolitique qu'on connaît en ce moment
avec l'Ukraine probablement que
l'influence
américaine et bénéfique alors l'Union
l'Union européenne c'est une puissance
potentielle c'est une puissance en
puissance c'est une puissance on est
l'Europe c'est la première puissance
commerciale au monde avec 450 millions
de consommateurs c'est colossal quand on
est là les Russes l'ont compris je pense
que Vladimir Poutine il s'attendait pas
à de telles sanctions parce que elles
nous ont fait mal aussi ses sanctions
nous voilà on veut défendre des grands
principes on fait la leçon reste du
monde mais surtout faut pas que ça
affecte notre petit confort
on ira mourir pour personne et on va pas
prendre trop de risques et la crise
ukrainienne a changé ça et on s'est
rendu compte que il fallait qu'on fasse
bloc il fallait qu'on soit ensemble que
la façon dont l'Union européenne allait
gérer cette crise c'était regarder
évidemment en Russie mais ça pouvait
être regardé aussi en Turquie ça pouvait
être gardé en Chine ça pouvait être
gardé dans d'autres zones du monde et
que ils allaient pouvoir continuer à
nous marcher sur les pieds et le
problème c'est que donc on parlait de
l'Europe de la défense pour l'instant il
n'y avait pas de consensus là-dessus
parce qu'il y avait pas de d'ennemis il
y avait pas de méchant face aux
Européens on n'était pas d'accord sur ce
qui constituait une menace pour les
États baltes pour la Pologne et autres
eux ils ont toujours dit il faut se
méfier des Russes on a peur des Russes
mais les Français les Italiens les
Allemands ils disent d'accord vous êtes
gentil avec vos russes mais nous le
problème est plutôt au sud c'est la
menace islamiste et donc il y avait des
décalages là on se retrouve avec 27
États qui se disent on a un problème
avec la Russie on doit se mettre
ensemble et c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu
l'unanimité pour des sanctions inédites
un coup de massue et ça c'était très
fort donc l'Europe est en train de
devenir une puissance après les
États-Unis c'est pas l'ennemi
donc du coup est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à une armée européenne dans le
contexte de la l'Ukraine et la Russie
qui ferait éventuellement une alliance
avec l'OTAN oui je pense que c'est très
important qu'on a une défense européenne
en tout cas je pense qu'on aurait tout à
y gagner à avoir des forces en commun
pour aussi peser et ne plus être en un
diplomatique géopolitique militaire face
à la Russie par exemple je pense qu'on
aurait tout à gagner l'Europe
aujourd'hui c'est un projet qui a 70 ans
est-ce que nos soldats sont prêts à
mourir pour le drapeau européen
ça veut dire quelque chose quand même
quand on est un combat quand on est un
combattant qu'on s'engage et qu'on doit
potentiellement qu'on peut
potentiellement mourir pour une cause
est-ce que la cause européenne est
suffisante c'est une vraie question
c'est une vraie question Valentin tu
levais la main justement avec le
contexte actuel en Ukraine ou même par
exemple le changement climatique la
montée du niveau de la mer l'Europe elle
va faire face à des vagues de à des
vagues de migration et comment
compte-t-elle les prendre en charge ce
qui est très intéressant avec les
migrations pareil c'était un motif de
désaccord entre les Européens c'est une
sorte de serpent de mer c'est-à-dire que
il y a toujours eu des velléités une
envie de la part de Bruxelles d'arriver
à une politique commune d'immigration et
d'asile mais il y a toujours des pays
qui n'en voulaient pas
tout simplement parce qu'il y avait des
pays traitement d'heure l'Italie la
Grèce Malte donc les pays du Sud
et
ceux qui s'enficient un peu les États
baltes les pays du Nord et autres
et les pays au milieu les Hongrois par
exemple qui disaient moi je vois pas
pourquoi il y aurait des quotas moi j'ai
pas envie de prendre des migrants sur
mon sur mon sol surtout que nous on est
des on est des gâteaux et on veut pas
avoir des musulmans etc donc il y avait
ce rapport de force et là c'est en train
de changer parce que avec le temps on se
rend compte en Europe que les problèmes
des uns deviennent 10 ans 20 ans 30 ans
plus tard aussi des problèmes des autres
et c'est ce qui fait qu'autour de la
table on va arriver à de plus en plus de
décisions communes et de politiques
communes et c'est pour ça qu'il y aura
une solidarité dans la gestion et dans
l'accueil des migrants on va on va
parler un petit peu de climat maintenant
parce que c'est aussi le sujet de ce
film Zara vous avez une question
pouvez-vous nous dire comment l'Europe
s'engage-t-elle concrètement dans la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
le 1 des points de départ des moments
historiques vraiment très important je
pense qu'on le voit dans le documentaire
c'était la fixation de cet objectif à
2050 de
voilà de d'Europe neutre en émission de
de gaz à effet de serre on parle d'une
révolution copernicienne on change tout
arriver à la neutralité carbone je vais
dire ça touche à notre industrie à notre
façon de vivre à notre façon de nous
déplacer ça change tout et en 30 ans
c'est à dire qu'on doit changer toutes
nos usines notre façon de nous déplacer
et et c'est dans la loi c'est pas juste
des grands principes des trucs comme ça
il va falloir il va falloir le faire
mais en fait ça touche à tout et c'est
l'Union européenne qui définit le cadre
fumée blanche je vous conseille européen
au bout de 10 heures de négociation
l'Union européenne dans son ensemble
s'est engagé à devenir neutre sur le
plan climatique d'ici 2050
monsieur chabel est-ce que vous avez
déjà rencontré Charles Michel
ah non j'ai jamais rencontré Charles
Michel j'ai déjà croisé
lavanda lion Emmanuel Macron ou d'autres
d'autres dirigeants d'institutions ou
des talents mais jamais Charles Michel
moi je l'ai rencontré
là où c'est très intéressant c'est que
c'est pas c'est pas Emmanuel Macron
c'est pas Barack Obama c'est pas
quelqu'un quand il rentre dans la pièce
tout le monde sait qu'il est là et tout
tourne autour de lui voilà Charles
Michel
il en impose pas mais il s'impose
toujours et en fait c'est ça qui est
fort c'est qu'on se rend compte que là
pour l'instant à ce stade d'évolution de
l'Union européenne à la tête du Conseil
européen il faut pas quelqu'un qui va
dire au 27 bon ici c'est moi qui décide
et c'est comme ça qu'on va faire parce
que ça ça va pas marcher lui c'est celui
qui va discuter avec chacun qui va
préparer le terrain qui va connaître
leur secret qui va savoir ce qu'il est
préoccupe là où ils peuvent aller là ils
peuvent pas aller et c'est lui qui va
dire ok vu l'état de la situation
comme ça on va la jouer comme ça donc
le facilitateur d'accord et c'est ça qui
peut faire que les autres vont l'écouter
et donc vraiment pour le job il est
la personnalité il a il a les atouts
qu'il faut c'est ça qui est intéressant
Agathe alors justement petit jeu de rôle
si vous aviez été à la place de Charles
Michel quels arguments auriez-vous
utiliser pour faire adhérer le Premier
ministre polonais aux résolutions dans
le dans le feu de l'action dans le
moment du sommet dans le moment le plus
tendu je crois qu'il a tout essayé tous
les arguments tous les arguments ils
sont passés mais en fait matteus
moravitzky il pouvait pas parce que en
Silésie ce sont ces électeurs donc cette
région polonaise où il y a beaucoup de
charbon et de mines de charbon ce sont
ces électeurs à lui
et je veux dire il pouvait pas pour les
beaux yeux de Charles Michel de toute
façon il allait il allait rien faire lui
ce qu'il voulait c'était sortir de là
avec un maximum d'argent pour pouvoir
dire en conférence de presse j'ai eu
beaucoup d'argent et en plus on fait pas
partie de l'accord mais réellement
formellement il fait pas partie de
l'accord mais c'est une question de
temps et il a immédiatement dans les
semaines dans les mois qui ont suivi mis
en oeuvre les mesures de de transition
déjà donc c'est pas juste parce que il
vient de boire une bière avec Charles
Michel et ils sont super copains parce
qu'ils ont découvert qu'il jouait au
ping-pong quand ils étaient jeunes qui
va tout lui céder
[Applaudissements]
effectivement
et toi Agathe qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que tu lui aurais dit au président
polonais pour le convaincre qu'est-ce
que j'aurais dit au président polonais
alors je pense que comme Charles Michel
je pense que j'aurais aussi joué la la
tactique de la complicité de l'amitié de
la bonne entente je pense parce que
c'est quand même très intéressant
justement de voir ce travail en amont
qui a été fait et bon je joue pas au
ping-pong mais je pense que j'aurais pu
j'aurais pu trouver un extraordinaire
j'aurais pu trouver un autre argument je
pense mais je pense qu'en tout cas oui
Charles Michel a bien a bien joué le
coup de la complicité et je pense que ça
a été un atout qui a fait peser la
balance est-ce que l'Europe elle en fait
assez
les choses pour interdire les bouchons
en plastique les trucs comme ça ça c'est
pas grand chose mais ça fait payer quand
même d'être parti quand même des grandes
puissances qui qui agissent sur
l'environnement mais ont taquine
l'Europe souvent on dit ouais l'Europe
c'est s'intéresse à la courbure des
bananes des concombres des trucs comme
ça des trucs du quotidien idiot
moi j'ai plutôt tendance à défendre ça
par exemple il y avait eu un texte un
projet de texte sur les urinoirs à tout
de suite ça fait rigoleries noires et
quoi l'Europe qui s'intéressent à la
cuvette des WC et autres mais en
fonction de la quantité d'eau qui a
quand on tire la chasse s'il y a trop
d'eau vous imaginez 450 millions
d'Européens qui qui tirent la chasse
chaque jour si on réduisait d'un litre
la contenance des réservoirs mais ça
changerait tout et là on se dirige
potentiellement vers des conflits pour
l'eau dans les dans les dizaines
d'années à venir et donc on a tendance à
railler à se moquer de l'Union
européenne en disant arrêtez avec vos
urinoirs et en fait c'est c'est majeur
et il y a des pays en Europe qui ont
jamais le réflexe de s'intéresser à ça
et donc c'est pour ça que c'est
intéressant parfois que ce soit réfléchi
que ce soit conçu à Bruxelles et qui est
des directives dans ce sens on peut
toujours faire mieux après je pense que
ce qu'on pourrait faire aussi c'est
écouter beaucoup ce que nous on a à dire
parce que c'est un peu notre avenir
c'est dans quelques années on sera à
votre place on aura peut-être aussi nous
des enfants et donc c'est important d'en
parler et je pense que pour avancer il
faudrait aussi beaucoup nous écouter
écouter nos propositions et avancer tous
ensemble Rudy une question qui s'adresse
à vous deux pensez-vous qu'il serait
pertinent de faire entrer des
représentants d'ONG ou bien des citoyens
engagés tels que Greta Tomberg au sein
des débats européens
c'est très important c'est très très
important je pense que notre génération
est probablement celle qui se sont le
plus concerné le plus qui est la plus
inquiète par rapport à l'urgence
climatique c'est véritablement une
urgence à laquelle on est on est
probablement aussi la génération qui
qui s'engage le plus sur ces
questions-là et donc il y a un véritable
enjeu d'abord démocratique à mon avis à
impliqué davantage les jeunes dans cette
prise de décision à rendre les espaces
de participation démocratiques plus
inclusives pour les jeunes pour notre
génération
pour qu'on nous écoute d'abord mais nous
écoutez c'est pas suffisant on voit que
l'État Thunberg qui est écoutée qui
accueilli pendant des sommets très bien
il y a pas qu'elle d'ailleurs il y a
aussi beaucoup d'autres jeunes qui
s'engagent sur ces questions là ça c'est
très bien mais c'est pas suffisant et
c'est un enjeu démocratique je le disais
mais c'est aussi
enfin voilà face à l'urgence climatique
il faut aussi donner aux jeunes le
pouvoir de prendre ses décisions là je
pense que voilà nos parents sont pas
plus légitimes que nous pour prendre des
décisions sur
sur les enjeux climatiques donc oui je
pense que c'est pertinent c'est
extrêmement important qu'on soit écouté
mais aussi qu'on soit inclus dans les
processus de prise de décision Zara on
écoute
coute comment voyez-vous l'Europe dans
une dizaine d'années voire une
cinquantaine d'années déjà sur m'avait
demandé il y a 6 mois
si elle ressemblerait à ce qu'elle
reçoit ce à quoi elle ressemble
maintenant déjà parce que c'est ça qui
est extraordinaire avec l'Europe c'est
que l'Europe avance à travers les crises
et les tabous tombent les uns après les
autres il y a des choses qui paraissent
impossible
à horizon un an 10 ans 20 ans et il y a
une crise et boum tout le monde se met
d'accord moi non plus je sais pas ce que
sera l'Europe dans 10 ans on n'en sait
rien ce que j'aimerais que l'Europe soit
dans 10 ans c'est une Europe plus
aboutie beaucoup plus intégrée avec une
répartition des compétences et et
voilà des prises de décision entre
l'échelon local régional national
européen qui ont beaucoup plus de sens
aussi ce qui est intéressant aujourd'hui
c'est de voir que personne en France
remet en cause le fait que la France
soit la France et que ce soit une
république aujourd'hui on remet encore
souvent en cause l'appartenance à
l'Union européenne comme si c'était un
choix non je veux dire dans dans 20 ans
au train où vont les choses il y aurait
plus aucun pays membres de l'Union
européenne qui ferait partie du G20 donc
qui serait à la table de ceux qui
décident de la marge du monde et notre
seule façon de continuer à faire partie
de cette table des grands décideurs
c'est c'est à travers notre siège en
tant qu'Union européenne et ça il faut
que ça rentre et ça va rentrer c'est un
jeune projet par rapport aux États-Unis
les États-Unis sont en état jeune mais
l'Union européenne c'est encore plus
jeune et c'est ça avec ce qui s'est
passé à l'Ukraine avec avec ce qui se
passe pour le climat etc on est en train
de prendre conscience de du côté
indispensable du caractère indispensable
de l'Union européenne
et on va s'arrêter là l'émission est
déjà terminée merci infiniment il y a
Anthony Noguès c'est d'avoir pris le
temps de répondre à toutes ces questions
merci à vous les élèves vous pouvez vous
applaudir bravo vous avez extrêmement
bien être travaillé bravo pour vos
questions vos réflexions ou te remercie
aussi votre professeur documentaliste
qui nous a permis de mettre en place ce
formidable programme et puis vous aussi
prof élève vous pouvez nous écrire pour
participer à l'émission c'est d'ailleurs
comme ça qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes au
Grand Quevilly tout près de Rouen et Z
évidemment revient très vite avec une
nouvelle classe et un nouveau
documentaire parce qu'il n'y a pas d'âge
pour questionner le monde et c'est une
image allez salut les élèves salut salut
salut salut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soleil c'est moi qui le fait
voilà c'est la tradition